joining me now is larry kudlow host of
kudlow on fox business former trump
economic adviser
uh larry wonderful to see you as always
tonight um the one outstanding issue uh
that could further
hasten america's decline is this
so-called reconciliation bill apparently
they've whittled it down to two trillion
dollars
and we're all supposed to be thrilled
about that like two trillion is just you
know
you know this popcorn they can pop on
the on the stove no big deal uh
does this bill need to die larry are we
in big trouble
well listen save america kill the bill i
mean that's still my motto 2 trillion is
unimpressive because they're all these
accounting gimmicks in there so you know
they're scoring
child allowances will be for one year
but in fact it's a trillion dollars over
10 years and they will do everything
they can to continue it for 10 years
there's only
two obstacles to this crazy 5 trillion
dollar plus taxing and regulating and
spending bill
one is joe manchin who is against the
spending and the other is kirsten cinema
who is against the taxing the two of
them make a lovely couple they're
washington's most important power couple
of the moment
they can stop this bill the bill needs
to be stopped and i just want to add to
that quickly
these
attacks on fossil fuels oil and gas and
coal have decimated our energy base and
this was a government-driven policy
where two million barrels of oil per day
lower than we should be that would cut
the gasoline price in half and the other
thing is the bidens were asleep at the
switch on this supply side shortages the
container ship back up in the la and uh
long beach ports i mean they didn't take
any action to have it go
24 7. that was a governmental decision
the longshoremen the unions the bidens
want to unionize everything the
longshoremen did not want to go 24 7 and
with all this talk about infrastructure
there's nothing in there that would get
updates on machinery and automation in
these ports and that's also because the
longshoremen oppose it and americans
consumers do not want to wait they hate
shortages they hate austerity they want
prosperity and government central
planning is not the answer the job i
mean i'm thinking again about the fact
that we were able to ramp up
manufacturing in the united states in
the 1940s in a few years 1930s and 1940s
to win the war okay we could win the war
with u.s manufacturing might and our
incredible courageous servicemen we
could do that but we can't get a bunch
of a cargo unloaded from some
some ships coming into our it's
unbelievable what's happened to
because i think you're right the
the only thing the opening should have
is when you're putting all those
individuals running the byte
administration uh laura it looked to me
like the junior varsity it may have been
the freshman team they are unaware
they're simply not aware of the
situation they're amateurism because
they're bad it's amateur hour that's
right
that's right all right i got to play
this one that's right theology
oh yeah this is all purpose
ideology prevents them
right that means let me let me let me
show you my striking figure government
larry hold on the striking figure that i
think spells out
why biden uh what biden has done the
atlanta fed's gdp growth estimate is now
point five percent
it was six percent growth just two
months ago obviously under trump that
our growth would be flying high now
because he wouldn't have done all this
anti-energy nonsense and borrowing uh at
least i hope he would have done the
borrowing but larry uh what's causing
that uh point five percent
well look part of that is there were no
cars to buy so consumer spending looks
very weak it's really not but there are
no cars to buy because of these
container backups because they all had
semiconductors that the cars need so you
can't produce them and they're not in
the showrooms the second point is the
inflation bulge whether it's temporary
or permanent it doesn't matter it is it
exists today and we're only making it
worse by creating this economic uh
scarcity this environment of scarcity
you know those people in the washington
post are writing this stuff hey listen
only wealthy people have patience you
don't really need all these consumer
goods that is vintage jimmy carter i got
to tell you that is malays talk what's
really at the root of this is very bad
government decisions and that's why i'm
touting mansion and cinema both of them
by the way should call up donald trump
and ask to become republicans because
there's no place in the democratic party
for sensible moderates anymore which is
a shame right but it'll be what it'll be
and i don't see the changes being made
all right
changes
now well joe manchin right now if he
goes along with this he's actually
working against the interests of the
people of west virginia they want
sensible policy this is reckless policy
that's right so joe manchin you're
better than that you've got to be better
than that i think i think kristin cinema
is better than that uh larry thank you
great to see you as always hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else